you
[Music]
so it's great to have a JD Walker in
India from SR I in Princeton New Jersey
RJ will give a talk on I guess some of
the recent work they've been doing with
the u-dub and some other universities on
vision and language and so RJ is the
head of vision and learning at SR I he
did his PhD at RPI and then he went to I
think that was in the days of the
startup business so he he did his
wavelet compression stuff went to a
start-up and then got disillusioned and
then went to Merle in Cambridge and then
he came to SR I in 2008 and since then
he's been there and I remember IJ was
the first one at SII
to start a completely new thread on
human understanding what we call human
understanding in hololens and here and I
still remember that you know us had just
gone in not just but for a few years
they had been in Iraq US Army and one of
the biggest problems they used to face
is they they knew how to fight they
didn't know how to deal with civilians
and that was the major problem in Iraq
so DARPA started a project called good
strangers how can you train people to be
to be good strangers you know in a
strange land so AJ was the first one who
went in this concept to DARPA and said
you know we'll mount connects and other
sensors and we'll have a feedback loop
where there is some scenarios being
played in virtual reality and people
start interacting and that was that
became a hit really
he built a system with connects and
other kinds of sensors and people would
get trained in doing good strangers and
I think since then he's continued and he
also has worked on many many things both
at sra and she used to be a GE and great
to have you here so a JD Walker
thank you very much for that kind
introduction I should point out that I
prepared me into a Sarah and he was my
direct supervisor there for a very long
time so I'll start off by first talking
and just a little bit about SSRI and in
particular the scent of a vision
technologies
then I will commerce cover some of our
work on applications of joint multimodal
embeddings and then I'll hand it over to
you who will describe to you some of our
work on using a graph based modeling of
activity so so Asri is a non-profit
research institute the business model is
contract research the clients are
primarily government but a reasonable
number of private clients or commercial
clients also the model being that you
incubate the technology with government
funding and then over time transition it
to commercial activity
I guess these statistics are interesting
in the sense that about half of the
company consists of people who have at
least a master's so it's definitely a
bit of a PhD heavy organization but you
see that the other half is not which
means that there's an emphasis on
development or advanced prototype so
rather than just research pure research
and there is all this you know these are
all the startups that I come out the
most famous one I guess is Siri the
iPhone so now we're in the information
in computing Sciences Division it has
four labs and it is you can say it's a
sort of microcosm of a Sarah at large
very similar composition of skills and
so forth and I'll jump directly to the
Center for vision technology so one big
claim to fame we have is that the
ten-yard line in four
always developed so this hadith has
himself presented this slide many times
so it kind of feels strange showing it
to you folks and we have about 80 plus
people this number might be off a thing
has gone back up now some 87 86 or some
yeah
and so now currently the work you know
here are some examples so one is the GPS
denied navigation activity augmented
reality and then at the bottom bottom
right is the human behavior modeling
that had proposed referring to so it
started off with that project and it has
now been parlayed into the driver
behavior modeling for Toyota's concept
car so it will be featured in at the
2020 Olympics as part of Toyotas so and
then on the left there we'd reduced you
know typical video retrieval which to
this crowd you know I don't have to
explain this is another way of looking
at the technologies so intelligent there
are some cat technology under
intelligent mobile platforms human
understanding human interaction and then
multimodal data analytics and machine
learning what's happening is that in the
process of developing these technologies
we are also developing certain core
machine learning techniques and offline
I'll be happy to engage with you on
those so this is the augs
and let's see yeah so there are four
managers here who report to me and so
Mohammed amar does some I'll just give
you some sample project so he does
joined computer humans storytelling
under a DARPA program so that's why he
likes to call it creative AI Amir works
on the human behavior understanding
which in which is working on both driver
behavior and also on human-computer
dialogue management
he works on multi modal analytics both
of ground imagery as well as overhead
imagery we work for government client
imagery is an important part of what we
do and Nick is a systems person now what
I will do is just play since you know we
mentioned
no no the the video over here where I'll
just just show these couple of videos so
this is our you know this is the driver
behavior console and so I just wanted to
give you a flavor of how so the main
challenge in this kind of problem really
is the tremendous lighting variation
that the auto environment offers you
that's the biggest that's the absolute
biggest challenge right because the
variation is just immense and so Amira's
developed pretty strong I mean what we
have is way beyond this but it's not
ready for public release and then on the
other side of this is the the full-body
behavior which is what we developed in
that project that I picked was referring
to which is you know we are looking at
facial expressions gears posture
gestures and also speech tone so we do
some amount of audio also in this lab
and you will see later we do some text
and then we are also interested in
interaction between individuals so for
example on the Left we have looked at
children doing pair programming on the
right people building a tower playing at
our game together so this was all done
that stuff was published at the learning
and knowledge conference this was
published at IDC me for example so in
addition to the real-time work that I
showed you this will this part of the
talk zeroes in on our social media
analytics work so this is something I do
with my young colleague Karen chica this
is like of those four groups this is yet
another group where basically just the
two of us and so are interested in
social media analytics from the
government side comes from detecting
people who are trying to recruit for
extremist causes right and so we look
for extremist content extremist behavior
and so forth that's why the government
is interested and the key is that these
platforms have two things that make them
really stand out one is the sheer volume
and the other is the complete lack of
constraints meaning that people can put
whatever content they like people even
may put a day's worth of Fitbit data on
social media anything goes
right so it's truly multimodal truly
vast and so what it does is that it
stretches the boundaries of whatever
standard problems you want to solve
you're going to solve a much more
magnified version of that problem so
that is sort of by you know in the way
of motivation and platforms that we have
looked at include Twitter Instagram we
have put Facebook over there but no we
don't have access to Facebook but and
surprisingly YouTube functions as a
social medium the next time you go to
YouTube just keep this observation in
mind now the problem that we were
interested in was modeling content
reaction so given a piece of content who
would be interested in it and given a
group of users what kind of content
would they be interested in we were
interested in this problem because if
you are trying to track extremist
activity when you see extremist content
you should know which group is going to
be triggered by this kind of content
right so that now obviously on the
commercial side it has an application to
advertising and so forth but for now so
so more on the technical side then what
we are interested in is taking the
modalities of speech of text and images
and then projecting them into a common
multi modal semantic embedding space so
basically you can say this is a multi
modal generalization of embedding such
as word to back you can just see that
that's pretty much almost exactly what's
happening there that you are you have
paired data and the pairing is what is
important so now why we are interested
in applying it to social media is that
this is a highly unsupervised kind of
technique so in social media that is
good because getting labeled social
media data is a you know basically not
possible and the social media has in
and pairing so those are two things that
give us encourage us to so now there are
some research questions associated with
multimodal embedding so you have seen
work I'm sure on zero short learning on
captioning visual question on selling
learning better word embeddings and so
forth so now our interest in this came
from the social media analytics so we
were interested in
first of all seeing if we could push 0
short learning in a new direction
and we were also interested in finding
out if you could embed the users and the
content in the same space so treat users
as an additional modality and then have
a three-way embedding so that I could
have seamless three-way retrieval
between all of those modalities so that
led us to first this problem called 0
short object detection so this is
something we published at ECC 2018 this
came out of a project that we started as
summer intern under the DARPA metaphor
project and what we are interested in
here is the not merely object
classification we want to also localize
the object and it should be previously
unseen so I'll just flip through these
in the interests of time this is just
some background material right that when
you want to this is basically saying
that there are these existing techniques
like yolo faster our CN n SSD etcetera
but scaling beyond a few hundred objects
and detecting completely new objects
still beyond the reach of these kinds of
techniques so now what is zero short
learning so let's you know I'm going to
state the obvious just so at least we
have common terminology so the idea is
that you learn ik learn from scene
classes but then you predict on unseen
classes so that is the
can say a good definition of of zero
short classification so then the
question is what is zero short detection
so this illustration is telling you what
that is our detection is that in
addition to saying that there is a cat
in the picture you are also saying
exactly where the cat is are exactly
where the dog is right and so now and
now you're going to do this in a zero
shot
fashion now all the other problems such
as occlusion viewpoint clutter etcetera
still come in play there are some
certainly obvious applications like
robotics and surveillance and the
question is do we really need thousands
or training examples to deal with a new
category and our answer based on what we
have looked at is no so this is just a
sketch of our approach to this problem
so what are some you know so first of
all we are we want to take previous work
in zero short learning we don't want to
create something out of whole cloth but
then the task is how do we model the
background so what happens is that when
you have all only its previously seen
objects then the definition of
background becomes very clear because it
is whatever is not in the class of seen
objects is the background the moment you
have objects that you've never seen
before now there is a new class so there
is the typical background which you
could call a stuffed class like sky or
wall or water you know right etc but now
you have a class of objects that you are
not seen before and that may also merge
into the background so that presents a
bit of a challenge and you will now see
the how we have dealt with this kind of
problem as we go forward and then what
we have also done is that you know you
will never have enough training data
that is for sure for any problem of this
nature just because it is so big in
scale so what we have done is you
explored this business of dense sampling
of the semantic space so wherever you
are certain of what you know what you do
is that you try to sample close to that
and make so even though you don't have
label data but you try to sample over
there and try to make the embedding very
dense around that particular location so
now what is our baseline method we use
this our CNN architecture but that's
really not the point I mean you know you
could use any other architecture also
for this kind of method and we are just
showing you some sort of you can say
already some result where what we have
done is we carried out training on the
scene classes and then when we trust
test on the unseen classes so shoulder
and skirt were part of the set of unseen
classes and you see that this actually
does in fact detect the skirt and the
shoulder presumably presumably because
in the world embeddings there was enough
similarity seen between say skirt and
shirt or you know proximity between
short and shoulder and so forth and then
there was some joint learning or the
visual attributes as well which managed
to give you this kind of result
embedding space yes all these concepts
will be nearest neighbors versus other
concepts that's right so the idea is
that when you're trained is embedding
what we are trying to do is you are
trying to pull similar things together
and you are trying to pull the similar
things apart so you are depending very
heavily on the pairing if it did not
have paired data the embedding would not
work what is the testing scenario like
like in object detection
it's basically bombing boxes being in
this case when you say testing on unseen
classes is it exactly the same yeah
there were born boxes and being labeled
that's right there boundary basa there
being labeled and then you say that okay
I was able to see that there's a skirt
there even though it was not part of I
didn't train on skirts now on the
lighter side
you know at another place where I gave
this talk this young lady in the
audience pointed out that that's not a
skirt that's a dress so so yes so what I
always says that that's a reflection on
the gender composition of the people who
made this algorithm and the sizes of the
body box are basically whatever these
networks generate yes that's right and
back of boxes right so there is no
structural information embedded into our
system right now so what would prevent
let's say shoulder getting a dress no
that is very true you know so partly
with these deep learning systems you can
come only so close to giving some kind
of a an intuitive answer after the fact
I could try to tell you that somehow you
know this fabric need to be a bit floppy
and you know I mean overall the nature
of the relationship in fabric and skin
with lower body or tire is different
from upper body attire so if you have
enough of training data that kind of
thing will be learnt but having said
that I'm not telling you that that is
the answer to the question it's it's a
it's an educated guess I would say
frankly yeah so that's the general idea
and now here are some mathematical
details here that what you are doing is
your first you know you you first
trained the embedding you know at once
and now you are projecting it using the
linear projection and then what you are
asking me right you are taking the G box
and then comparing it to the label so
basically it is a box by box result as
it was right and then what you are doing
is you are pushing embedding for similar
boxes and class labels your time
random together and so forth so now the
interesting part comes in which is one
of the innovations in this approach
which is what allowed the solution to
the problem
so what detection model is with a fixed
number of classes do is that they will
add an additional background class and
that's like some kind of container class
that just takes care of whatever is not
in the same classes this is not like
that so when we try to just use a single
background class we end up not getting
very good results in certain cases and
the reason for that is that these
previously unseen objects merged into
the background so they get classified as
background and they are not seen at all
so what we are done basically is come up
with a way that assigns latent classes
it allows us latent classes to emerge so
we these are not labeled but what you do
is you make a distinction between
background that are background areas
that are just stuff and background areas
that actually correspond to some latent
classes that may or may not correspond
to previously unseen objects so once you
do this kind of a thing we find that we
are in fact able to get better results
and now in the densely embedded space
what we are doing is you know the the
issue is that you have this embedding
space can be very sparse you have no
control over the density and we all know
that any kind of interpolation method
will work well if it is being done in a
dense region you want the points to be
dense so what we are done over here is
basically we augmented the training data
set with just additional classes where
we are no there is no overlap with the
unseen classes we you know do our best
to not cheat and but then what you are
trying to do basically is you are trying
to take whatever areas you know and you
want to pack them
more data so that those areas become
denser so now what we have done is that
we have worked with the Miss cocoa and
visual genome data set and now we did
this split right where with MS cocoa we
had total of 65 so 48 seen and 79 say no
visual genome has more classes in it and
we see an immediate consequence of this
now these are some more details but I
think in the interest of time I can skip
some of these details but the idea
basically is that you know this is sort
of you can say our experimental
framework this is the this is the
framework that we are using to run these
tests and so what happens is that for
the visual genome having this kind of
procedure where you are letting these
latent classes immerse in the background
actually helps and you get the best
results that is not quite evident in the
MS cocoa case and that is our theory is
that that is because in visual genome
you have a larger number of objects
presumably when you have a larger number
of objects to present a greater
challenge and that is when some benefit
is seen for this kind of method of
having a latent background classes and
so forth and so here is some more now
there are some good classes and there
are some bad classes and these are
obviously obviously you know you all
agree with me that mistakes are more
interesting than what you get right and
so when you look at this so you see for
example over here that it gets zebra
wrong and later on you will see you know
it persistently called zebras on this
just somehow does not recognize zebras
right whereas it does is saw you saw
that it is able to detect things like
skirts and buildings and cakes chairs so
forth so
yeah there's a little more detail but
I'll skip ahead to some visual results
so the result most of these results are
as expected I mean for example this R as
a result is fairly obvious uh-huh you
know it is picking up a bus
my favorite result is this one I had to
you know I made a double-take with this
one I first thought it was a dog myself
but it's actually a cat but this system
thinks it's a dog but that's good I mean
you know you know Hong Joo young Zhang
used to be with Microsoft and he once
told me that when your system makes a
mistake you failed it okay it's real
it's not so this is a fascinating
mistake in the sense that I think I
think that is the pointy ears that
somehow this thing is learning and it
thinks that it's a dog right but for the
most part it's not bad at all is
actually getting a lot of these things
now here you see there are you add this
question right look it made exactly that
mistake see if you think the XS skirt it
saw the fabric and skin boundary and it
thinks it's a skirt but it's not right
so it does get those things wrong
because probably because it the thing
that you pointed out there is no
structural information I captured now it
persistently thinks that you know it has
found cattle over here at some level
this is reassuring in fact later on you
will see we have tried some matrix where
what I encourage my folks to think about
was that you maybe you think of an
ontology and try to look for similarity
one level above so problem is taking a
zebra for cattle is not as bad as
mistaking zebra for doorknob so that's a
much more serious mistake so there are
levels at which you can test how well
this kind of technique is working
no but in cases where they were
overlapping in the two datasets but but
some other domain would be very
different right like let's say the cats
to my knowledge no mine all is not but
I'd have to go back and check them if I
allow a few oh right right right right
so that's a very good question I have
wrestled with that all the time I work
with machine learning and what I found
is that it's it's kind of hard to say I
mean he did try current tried some top
cat type experiments right very so there
are there we did get some results like
that back there yeah possible that you
know what are you calling unseen
concepts yes what you saying unseen is
in the visual domain but they are there
in the X domain right absolutely
so they are not unread they are unseen
but they are not undressed much at all
in which case in which case it goes off
course like this no wonder it's still
fascinating that it's somehow thought it
was cattle but again I won't read too
much into that who knows you know what
it you know what it let's don't do we
don't necessarily know and this actually
gives us the cue to ask another
questions how do you judge the success
of an embedding because that's our next
problem here because we start off with
this multimodal embedding for social
media now and the reason we are
interested in an embedding is that we
want to have we want to solve the
problem I mention earlier which is that
given a piece of content who would be
interested in this content given a user
what kind of content would they be
interested we are interested in solving
that problem and so yes we can certainly
if we had a joint embedding that would
be very nice and now why are we
interested in this kind of thing
specifically there's another reason also
like I was telling you earlier there is
absolutely no constraint in social media
prep solutely
think and pop up and so you need to deal
with that so it's a much harsher
environment than relatively domesticated
environments such as I miss Coco or vgg
so what so that's what we are interested
in over here and so we come up with this
kind of embedding technique where what
we are doing is we are using images
posted by the user as a stand-in for the
user so we really are not you know
obviously I have to take some user
attribute and use that as a stand-in for
the embedding you don't literally embed
the user so in this case what we are
doing is we are just taking the images
that the user has posted and then
embedding those so we are using the same
framework as we did earlier but now we
are attaching this user label with that
image so that we are maintaining it as a
separate modality and so now I'll play
you a video of this demo so now what
this allows you to do is carry out a
four-way retrieval so what we have is a
so we have text we have users we have
images and then we have also done some
unsupervised clustering of the users
right and so we have user clusters also
again what we do is that we use an image
as a stand-in for the user cluster and
we are able to embed user clusters also
in the same framework so what this
allows you to do therefore is that you
can retrieve based on text you can
retrieve the other three modalities
right so so what has it typed over there
I cannot read the thing too small yeah
it says Amazon rainforest and so you get
some images related to that you get the
users who are interested in that kind of
topic and so forth then you can go all
over the place I play you that we do in
a moment and so there is there are some
details here on this slide on how the
embedding what kind of metric
are being used and so forth now what we
are done here is we have taken one month
or Twitter data right and we wanted all
this to unsupervised so what we did was
we collected one month or Twitter data
and we took the top few hashtags right
so we just chose some arbitrary numbers
if we want because we wanted some we
wanted some density to the data you know
if there's a hashtag with just one entry
that's going to come in and just sit
there right so we got that so we ended
up with about 10 to 12 million tweets
about a million images and 40,000 users
these are months worth of data and it's
surprising what this kind of thing
actually ends up learning now this is
where we carry out the kind of
experiments that you were talking about
where what we do is we use ranking and
we try to figure out well you know
whether the rank makes sense or not and
just as a sanity check so we first test
only with text only with the images or
only with users and we find we're at
least much better than random and then
as we start adding modalities as we
start pairing them up you see that the
rank starts to improve and then here are
some results with with other with other
variations and this is I mean this is in
general it's a bit of an interesting
problem that you know exactly how do you
how do you evaluate an embedding right
how do you believe in embedding how do
you know what it is learnt and all that
so our operational definition is that if
for our task it gives results that make
sense then we believe this embedding and
and that's you know we sort of have a
restricted definition of the efficacy of
the now you see that we have played
around with different kind of things
right you can use it with glove which is
pre trained on a very large corpus or
you can limit it because there are some
interesting aspects on the text side
also the interesting aspects are
that the kind of language you see in
social media is very different from what
you see in the formal document that
things like glove and were Tuvok have
been trained on so lots of informal
language lots of these so-called stop
words so you have to do some cleaning
processing and all that so there is that
on on that side of things and so here
there are some more detailed results
where the joint model you know
are you using a GRU instead of
convolutional excuse me
network and so forth the user clusters
that I showed you what we do is that
those are unsupervised but we find that
interestingly these clusters actually
seem to make some sort of semantic sense
for example this seems to be around you
know British politics this box over here
the other ones we have put some images
so we see soccer images and soccer
related themes are sort of falling
together and so forth and so basically
what we are doing right now is we are
trying to write all this up and then the
the easy CV part of course is done now
but this part with the social media this
will we are waiting for the right kind
of forum to publish this what I will do
is I will quickly play you a video and
then I'll hand it over to you to talk to
you about so now you see this is the so
I already told you about this data this
is one month or Twitter data and so
forth and now see types in over there
heal type in the box she types in say
vegan food so many types in vegan food
with the embedding he gets this
retrieval so it's interesting about one
month or Twitter seems to have images
related to vegan photos
use labels associated with images when
their meetings are created yeah
basically captions yeah
caption sometimes it's loose also if
there's no caption but there is a some
kind of text associated with that tweet
that's the difficulty with this kind of
data but now you see that it is doing
retrieval all over the place right
retail starting from the image side
writable again starting on the tech side
but also from the user side or the user
cluster side so we are done this kind of
work where we are interested only in
rabble-rousing video we've published at
ICM i but this is a generalization of
that work now you have a general content
model which allows you to predict given
a piece of content who would be
interested in it so what I'll do is that
I will pause over here and I can
certainly take a couple of questions and
let me the surprising results are the
kinds of topics that pop up for example
we typed in fashion not quite knowing
what to expect anyway very surprised you
type in some designer or something the
breadth of topics is a big surprise with
this because there is no way for us to
actually prove that there is no easy way
for us to probe we're yeah so I'll hand
it over to you she'll tell you about
okay next I will switch to gear a little
bit talking about some of the video
analysis work we have done so this is
also included in the multimedia because
video is one source of the data format
so in here we just use action
segmentation as our task this is a slide
to show that action segmentation needs
to be done at different granularity
levels and to segment long videos when
to do inference over long temporal spell
in order to include the dependencies
causalities and also some temporal
ordering of the actions but at at the
same time we need to provide sufficient
details to differentiate two similar
actions even at very short temporal span
so to support these two requirements
actually we started to work on this
graph based a representation so we cut
the activity object attribute graph so
basically it has two levels on the top
we have the record activity graph so it
treats traces multiple threads of
activities so this level we can do
inference over long temporal span to
include causality dependencies and
ordering of the actions on the bottom
level we have the object attribute graph
this one we have detailed information
about the objects associated with the
activity or action as well as their
attributes status or status changes so
with this level with this amount of
detailed information we can
differentiate two similar actions and
also in our object attributes graph as I
mentioned we also check the status
change of the objects or even the actor
in this way we can not only infer the
explicit observations but also implicit
consequences so this is important for
some applications where the observations
are noisy we have mister detections or
even sometimes we don't have the
observation at all because of the non
overlapping camera field of view so this
is a high level like illustration of our
framework on the bottom we have the
input image frames then we extract
different kinds of all kinds of
descriptors including objects attributes
actors actions motions and also
sometimes
we included the seeing descriptors then
based on this spatial temporal graph
then we apply what we call the stacked
spatial temporal graphic illusional
Network I will give you more details
later but our network has three major
improvements the first we allow
arbitrary temporal connections so that
we can account for large amount of graph
deformation and also as I mentioned we
will use all kinds of descriptors object
actions things to deal with complex
activities so we need a method to
support features or support nodes with
different feature length yes so I think
here we have different kinds of nodes
you will see we have like object notes
here and also actual notes actually in
our implant implementation we also
include the sing notes and motion notes
so these nodes it's not it can be like
actor specific then we will have all
kinds of notes to describe different
expect of the actions so it's not like
we are dividing the notes per actor but
we will have
take your chair yeah that's object notes
so for action you will have object notes
so if we go back here so on the top we
have the this is the activity notes so
this add actions but on there for each
activities we will have the actors as
well as the objects so actually in our
in our implementation we also add the
scene so all kinds of discreet good
descriptors so this notes can be like a
bunch of collection of the information
that is carried in the frame the edges
we have two types of edges so as you can
see the solid edges here we called the
spacial edges so this is just connect
the sum of the edges connect the
activities to the object to the objects
this will specify the role of the object
in the activities so the dashed edges we
call it the temporal edges so this is
connected across frame so we also
because in the surveillance scenarios
sometimes the cameras will not will not
have overlapped field views so the red
ones is still the temporal connections
but that is sometimes we may have missed
detections or even don't have observer
condition continuous observation of the
object or detector so these are the
edges for the graph yes yes I will in
the experiment I will show you what kind
of algorithm algorithms we use to
extract all the descriptors of the notes
okay then back to this on top of that we
use this our class structure to improve
generalization performance localization
accuracy and also be able to handle the
spatial temporal at different skills so
I will have slides for these three
improvements in the following slides
meanwhile working solo what is this I
wrote me so from the image some features
are going to get computed yes and
something is going to get updated right
at the dawn's yes
what gives update so the feature
describing the notes will be updated
each node is a vector yes each node is
represented by a vector these nodes are
basically like variables like they are
basically this whole thing is kind of
like a graphical model gray yes we use
this graphical model so that we can do
longer term inference but as well as the
graph carries the sufficient detailed
informations of the objects attributes
so that we can differentiate like
similar actions and short-term prospect
as well so this yeah this is a graph
representation so actually yeah and we
should make it clear that we do use some
algorithm so to extract the descriptors
from the frames then we construct the
graph then we use some craft
convolutional network on top of this
graph to do the action segmentation so
it's not like and to end just use one
giant neural network so we use some
neural network to to extract the
descriptors then constructed a graph
then to the graph collusion on top of
that yeah so this is just some
background information about graph
collusion on networks so actually I was
idea comes from the spatial vertices now
for the original implementation of the
graph konasana networks is only under
notes so it's only propagate based on
connection of the edges but the later
implementation they do consider the
edges can have
as well you can propagate notes
descriptors as well as the adjectives
critters but for our implementation we
use the original doesn't change yeah
that's the limitation of the original
graph convolution Network so here we
kind of still follow the like the
graphic needs to be fixed it's not a
dynamic graph no I'm sorry
so in here it is but in our
implementation way because we use all
kinds of descriptors we cannot allow
that so we actually generalize the
computation so that we can handle nodes
with different future nuts I will come
to that point later actually yeah the
edge actually is the matrix of the
features that when you do need the
features for the node to have same lines
but I will show some like workaround to
solve the problem where the nodes have
features of different lengths so for the
original spatial-temporal graph
convolution network it is used for the
scanning and paste action recognition so
again there are two major limitations so
in the original implementation for the
temporal connection is actually
degenerates to the great like data
structure it only allows the connection
of the same joint cross consecutive
temporal frames so that's why there are
spatial temporal collusion equation we
only see the spatial adjacency matrix
but temporal adjacent matrix
degenerative and also the features as
you mentioned the features they use
fixed lens so actually the feature
itself is very simple only the X Y
location of the joint as well as the
confidence
from the I believe it's open post output
so with these two limitations the
original spatial-temporal graph
conditional network cannot handle the
complexity of our network our graph
representation so again back to the
first improvement we want to use
arbitrary temporal connections so that
we allow different graffity of collusion
including newly detected objects miss
the detections including object and
activities so basically we have two
layers of the graph conclusion the blue
is the spatial graph collusion and the
green one is the temporal graph
convolution by adding the space I'm
sorry
temporal adjacency matrix we can handle
the connections in the temporal access
with different graph deformations here
so for features which varied lines
actually we kind of designed two
solutions on the left-hand side this is
a very straightforward implementation so
we just add a shallow layer of the
network to map the features of different
less to the same lines so this is a very
intuitive implantation but on the right
hand side and this is the implementation
we later used on the Shred data set
actually we because the notes itself
some of them note actually may have the
same less so we group those notes
together the map them to a one spatial
graph conditional Network so that's why
we have several special craft
conditional Network the output from the
spatial graph convolutional Network will
have the same lines then we can put them
in put them to one spatial and temporal
a graphic emotional network but one
object another object between one object
and
are they all based on special special
sort of weirdness or or how does the
grass get set up between so this for
multiple objects we we kind of build the
object to activity based on the
closeness the proximity of the object
and activities so but yeah you you but
here I think we do have problem because
when we group the spatial group the
nodes with the same lens together then
put them into one spatial graph
collusion or network within that
consider the connection cross group
actually we put that connection model
that connection in the temporal graph
constrain network because I'm a temporal
graph consonantal can handle arbitrary
connections so this is the kind of the
design tricks behind it so I would
expect your network to optimize them
somehow you actions between actors and
objects will define their action right
so actually when we construct the
representation we consider that which
nodes should be connected so that is the
current implementation I agree we can be
more dynamic about how to construct the
edges so actually right now we are
working on some attention mechanism so
yeah so that we can we just do not
assign connect or connect connector or
not connect we assign some attention so
that we have some dynamics yes I agree
that this is a very good part for the
basing permutation we do not have that
but we are working on improvements to
have the edges more dynamic so on
intuitively what you're currently doing
we will try to find correlations
these graphs temperament written that's
what you were coming to do you assume
that your representation is correct and
you're just trying to correlate between
the structures yes it's kind of because
if we just use one network to do that
when you go into higher higher level or
when you go into like longer term
respect you lose the details of each
individual actions so in this way we
kind of can't do the inference as you
said kind of just get to the correlation
like frame by frame in your longer term
but the graph is self at the spatial
connection it also carries the details
for the actions that is kind of the
improvements we see here do you have
might be modulating your audio keep the
mic okay okay
so some pros and cons for the naive
implementation again when we map the
features to a comment and lens or common
space we may lose information but the
network architecture is simple though is
when we use the more advanced ones we
reserved the information we need but the
design is more complex then the third
improvement we have is the hourglass
architecture so we power the idea for
the hourglass architecture usually used
for the convolutional net layers so but
we do have some like careful
architectural design I want to point out
first for these applications is we want
to do the action segmentation so we only
need the segmentation at the temporal
access so that's why when we do the
encoding we we have the future pooling
on the graph but when we do that
deconvolution we do not blow up to the
original graph dimension we only care
about it
Pro resolution and also when we do the
the convolution and the deconvolution we
also need to adjust the spatial temporal
addresses the matrix the dimension of
these those metrics accordingly okay
some results so we test this network
ultra data sets why is the cat 120 this
may not be that from like femurs but we
choose this since this data set they
give us some pre computed features so
that we we have fair comparison
comparison with other methods and the
second one we use the charades
oh yeah as you asked these are the
networks we used to compute the
descriptors for the spatial temporal
graph our surest intercepts so for the
cat 120 we compare with the state for
the art we were able to achieve about
for improvements in the f1 score and
also for charades when we use the V GG
as our backbone network we our
performances at the steep the art we use
a 3d we are comparable to the street art
but a little bit lower than the best
number but as I the patch the number
actually they already used the attention
mechanism which we are working on it
right now
so with the introduction of attention or
more dynamic graph we believe our
numbers can be pushed further so here I
will just show some of the ablation
studies the first obvious wise to
compare with just used the features
without any graph architecture we can
see 4.06 improvement in the mean average
precision we also want to see whether
the hourglass structure do does improve
the performance actually reseat about
2.5 improvement in the map
so actually we also want to see because
I pointed out the limitation from the
original spatial-temporal graph
convolutional network we try to
implement polina version of that but
since the original algorithm is applied
to a skeletal data we don't have a
complete replica here but we do just
degenerate our temporal connection to
adjust to the same nodes across one time
step and also we just use one type of
feature for other node we do not use
hourglass and we see five point for
improvement and next time some ablation
study with different types of input
features here we use one type of feature
to type the up to four types of features
we can see they gradually improve the
performance we also tested our network
with different temporal connections
because one of the improvement is to
generalize the network so that it can
handle arbitrary temporal connections so
actually from our experiment with
different architecture the optimal
number of temporal connections as well
as the improvement it introduced can
vary so our conclusion for the time
being is that the we do see improvements
but how to optimize the number of
temporal connections that is application
and architecture dependent I think with
that I just show some example results
this is the result from cat 124 actions
documentation and Charice data set so
for streets as you can see the ground
truth is not only the action but also
actually some objects here so I will
stop here for any additional questions
you're measuring the iuu of the detected
box yes in time yes
yes have visual visualization with this
box because simulation typically refers
to coloring pixels right oh yes for this
segmentation the action segmentation
means the segmentation at the temporal
spent not at the spatial four for the
current Network no it's just a
localization in the temporal access so
it's not the spatial semantic
segmentation it's actual segmentation in
the temporal access so we only see these
we just have locations yes yes you are
right
actually with the object we can look
nice but yeah I should say that for this
experiment we can localize but for
actions documentation task itself it
does not require the spatial
localization so it only requires the
temporal localization so when we do
those map so the Lu is also a CIO you
that's the how you allow the temporal
span not to the spatial locations data
sense
the mep numbers are relatively low in
general yeah right for sure it's so so
do you think that an evolutionary
approach will increase the performance
just by adding to these networks or
something completely new is required to
go to the next jump so actually this is
kind of our motivation to use graph
collusion network because we think the
end to end maybe it's not the solution
we do need some a structural data but
you use those and to enter to get
features the structure inference so
that's our motivation here but again as
I said this is just the first link plan
implementation we want to introduce more
complex graph that is adding the
that many dynamics with the attention we
also need to add different edge features
so for now if the edge is just saying
these two nodes connect or not we
believe with all this extra information
this can guide us to a better
performance with this graph structure
yeah that's our motivation here what
happens if you make a mistake in
populating it so for instance you are
saying that this person is is is
interacting with these two objects for
instance right now what happens if if
that early thing is wrong and the
construct is wrong in term for the time
being the spatial ones we kind of do not
have any correction but with the
attention we can allow more connections
the Latin Network to like attend to the
specific edges that's contribute to the
final decision but for the temporal wise
we already allow some some like
redundant connections so that's kind of
again we need the attention to make it
more dynamic for the time beauty of into
a learning it helps you avoid the sin of
any commitment yes committing to some
some interactions you learn and for this
one we kind of want to have some
structure in the inference otherwise at
the like that semantic level we think
when you need those structures instead
of like a black box let you choose
anything you can but agree how to make
the transition between them and to end
learning to how the network to the kind
of from the black box to the structured
data the interface how do you allow some
capability to correct early errors they
agree that kind of also some research
direction we can look into
graph structure lunamon said because I
remember Daphne Koller is to work a lot
on that
that's on its harder problem I guess
it's better to learn their potentials
very romantic intentions sorry this is
where I was pointing out that ultimately
if your goal is true we will figure out
what is responsible for a certain action
which objects which particular hand
movements it seems that if you have
explicitly represented nodes which can
ultimately tell you that then somehow
you need to represent that explicitly
write also m2 and typically requires way
more data and they think the last
CBPR the best paper was about how you
can combine different tasks to solve any
task and this combination which between
reduces they I think it also makes sense
to think here in German if you have very
high correlated errors then you have
some outliers so you do everything you
did here with the CRF or solve of must
be ended yeah actually I understand CR
and so on trying to really understand
conceptually what is use so the CAF
could be again a fully connected graph
yes all the nodes you have in the graph
could be the Lords of the CRF and you
can have this pairwise potential yes yes
actually I will see a couple of years
ago I live Behati he is kind of almost
of I will say one of the first couple of
papers try to use the features from the
deep networks then use the graph
representation to provide some structure
for complex or the action segmentation I
will see based on all these kind of
development of the graph conditional
Network I will see it's kind of more
powerful it learns more like benefits
learns more inference capability from
the data so agree yeah we did not do
comparison with the original paper yes
these are all like deep learning based
methods I will see yes but I believe
some paper did to comparison with the
original deep feature plus there have
kind of implementation the performance
the graph collusion or network or two
performs those methods this most
challenge right which one of the
challenges there is to localize actions
you mean special yeah making two more
yeah that one better than the straight
okay yeah we kind of pick up the streets
because in their notation they have some
a notation of the objects those kind of
but for the thermals they don't so this
is what they caught I cannot remember
what the super event me but I 3d 3d
commercial Network I think they do some
like hierarchical structure of the
events so that's why they call it is
super events but they also do some
attention
I do lose interest in German said that I
don't think so
the other work I showed you from the IDC
you know that there actually we had a
generative network at the bottom and
Dennis here at the top in fact trying to
combine the discriminative and generated
in one package right but our listeners
like you quite parallel to whatever
years found also that first of all the
first of all the distinction between the
reasoning part and this kind of part
also is prohibiting learning this
structures also much more power and see
convolution reverbs are also people
pinky feed-forward
there's no optimization and in Princeton
right in the sense that graphical models
you have to do that's right you ever
solve there may be problems let's find
the answer to some problem here there is
no optimization factors again yeah
training making even more obscure so my
observation is you do something with
data you do something with you these and
you act or you Agassi are up to it and
you get to percent point in the solution
doesn't seem to help here yeah we're a
revolution Sonia mercy honest we have to
solve some big problems and I guess here
at run time is just that way the
optimization is done in the training
process right you're kind of yeah yeah
okay thanks thanks about